an accidental explosion shot a 13-pound
rod through the brain of railroad
construction foreman Phineas Gage mr.
gage survived another 11 years but his
personality and demeanor seemed to
change next on children's books
science writer John Fleischman explains
why it's about 50 minutes I want to
welcome everybody here to bloom Anna to
children's bookstore in Cincinnati we
have a very special event today c-span
is here with us doing a program where we
have a very distinguished guest local
Cincinnati and John Fleischman will be a
second visit to the store and we're
thrilled to have him mr. Fleishman is a
currently a science writer for the
American Society for cell biology as
well as a freelance writer for several
magazines including children's magazines
we're here to he's here to discuss his
book Phineas Gage it's his first
children's book and he resides here in
Cincinnati with his family and let's
give him a round of applause hi guys
thank you for all coming out it's a
credible Turner thank you for coming all
right let's start with the serious stuff
here now I'm gonna ask you a question
this is a mass question this picture
right what holiday is this associated
with this image Halloween and what do we
do with this picture on Halloween
go trick or treating what else what do
you do when you'd want to be
trick-or-treating what do you want to
dress up as yeah but do you want to do
to people some of what scare them okay
this is a scary single symbol right it's
a skull and mostly we use it to scare
people now but we're going to talk about
another use for your skull a much better
use for your skull and what I want you
to do everybody's put your hands on your
face feel around feel your cheeks get
around the back around the top all right
where would you be without your skull
you'd be a puddle on the ground okay
everybody has a skull everybody here has
a skull yeah your head would be a puddle
and you you need your skull so it's not
something scary in and of itself it's
something very very useful and very very
important which is what the story of
Phineas Gage is about okay now some of
you guys have read this and probably saw
you haven't read this and so I'll talk a
little bit about what it's about and
first of all I want to tell you the
subtitle is a gruesome but true story
about brain science and the first thing
I wanna make clear to you is this is a
true story and that everything in this
book um I've been very careful to not
put it in in anything that I did know to
be true or that was nobody knows what
really happened okay some of the facts
we know in 1848 there was a man named
Phineas Gage who was building a railroad
in Vermont
now Vermont is a very stony place and
the way they built railroads in 1848 is
with a pick and a shovel and they you'll
see use blasting powder okay and they
would drill a hole in the rock and then
they would pour in blasting powder and
they would set it off it would break the
rock and then the man could come with
picks and shovels and take little pieces
away okay that's the first thing you
have to understand and I'm gonna explain
this thing free detail because you
really have to understand what he was
doing to know what happened to him okay
so he drilled a hole they drilled a hole
in the rock using a hand drill
okay and then Phineas was the man in
charge of all the workmen right some of
the workmen were digging up the broken
stone and putting it in carts and
hauling it away and other men were
drilling the holes but Phineas was the
man in charge of the blasting because
blasting powder is it's dangerous you've
got to be careful so only one person was
going to do the blasting and that was
Phineas Gage so they drilled the hole
and he he had an assistant who had the
powder and it's just black powder now if
you've ever seen a firecracker and I
don't suggest this but sometimes you can
see if it opened a firecracker you'll
see a black powder inside and that's
gunpowder
it's very dangerous stuff so I don't
recommend it anybody open a firecracker
but if you happen to see one that's
what's inside so what they did was he
would pour powder into the hole which
was like a cylinder okay in the rock it
was at the bottom and then they had to
put a fuse into it and then they had to
block it off now to do this Phineas Gage
had a thing called a tamping iron it was
about three feet long
they weighed 13 pounds okay now some
people think it was a crowbar but it
wasn't it was like it was an iron rod
it was pointy at one end and round at
the other you can imagine a baseball bat
made out of iron
except baseball bats have a big ring at
the bottom to keep your hands from
sliding off and instead of that ring it
would come to a point now the point was
for pushing the powder aside so he could
push the fuse into the hole right so you
had to get the fuse into the powder and
then he would turn the bar around to the
flats the fat end and that's what he
would use for tamping and tamping means
to press down okay got that part all
right so you pour the powder in then you
push the fuse in and then you poured
sand in the top and then you push the
sand down okay and then you would set it
off it would go bang and the sand would
make the force of the explosion go down
into the rock all right gone to such
great lengths to explain that to you
because this is now what happens here
it's Phineas with this rock he uses the
pointy dead
push the fuse down and then he turns it
around for the next step so he's got the
round side down he's holding it like
this okay and then something happens he
looks back over his right shoulder we
know this because when what happens next
at this point something goes wrong the
guy he's working with his assistant
doesn't put the sand in the hole and
instead Phineas either drops or bangs
the rod against the rock and it strikes
a spark and it sets off the Gunpowder
and then the gut rod shoots up out of
the hole and through Phineas his head in
a fraction of a fraction of a second it
goes completely through doesn't stay in
there a lot of kids say to me does the
rod was it hanging out of his head it
didn't stay it was like being shot with
the world's longest bullet like a
three-foot long so it went in under his
cheek right here and they came out in
the middle of his forehead like about
here if you want to put your finger
under your left cheek left cheek and put
your finger on the top that's the path
at fault okay this is a very interesting
place to get to go through your brain
okay now the interesting thing was it
went off with a bang right all the smoke
cleared away and when his men came
running he was sitting up and he was
talking he didn't was not even knocked
out he sat up immediately and was
talking and he was talking about what
had happened to him that the rod had hit
him in the head he knew what had
happened to him
okay so he was immediately alert and
there was so they took him into the into
the town and the doctors came and had to
look at it okay now what had happened to
Phineas Gage the rod had gone through
his cheek come out through his top his
head and had passed behind his left eye
and then up through the front
of his brain okay now your brain is a
really interesting shape now if you have
a bike helmet you know how it sticks out
in the front and it comes around the
back with a big bulbous part in the
front is there to protect the front of
your head so your brain is up here but
actually under your front of your brain
it's just your face so if you look at a
brain it looks like there's something
missing you know there's a a notchback
so what the rod did was it only went
through the front of his brain what they
call the frontal lobes okay now your
brain is going to pop open your heads
right and lift off your skull you could
see your brain has a big old thing at
the top that's the cortex and that's
where we do a lot of our thinking and
then there's this thing at the back
called the cerebellum and then there's a
long thing that sticks down that goes to
your spinal cord that goes down to the
rest of your body now guys reach around
to your necks if you're right where your
head pivots you feel that big bump there
if you feel down below that you can feel
these bumps to go right down your back
all the way down your back anybody know
what that is your spinal cord your spine
those are your vertebrae and they're
protecting your spinal cord okay and
that's what messages from your brain go
to your body right okay so Phineas Gage
sat up got into a cart went to a hotel
doctor came and treated him cleaned him
up and he survived and then basically
nobody believed nobody believed that
this had happened to him
I mean it's kind of hard to believe you
know someone got a rod through their
brain so the doctor who treated him
wrote it up and it was in a medical
newspaper in Boston and nobody believes
that either until this professor at
Harvard University professor Bigelow
wrote and said why don't you bring
Phineas to Boston so Phineas went to
Boston and he went with his iron he went
everywhere for the rest of his life with
his iron okay the iron
whose head and he appeared and at that
time they took what's called a life mask
with now has anyone ever had this done a
plaster on the face anything sometimes
to do with kids they do is you put two
straws up your nose so you can breathe
and then they put some grease on your
face and then you put plaster on it now
don't do this yourself this is something
that has to be done by somebody knows
what they're doing but then they can
take off and they have a mold of your
face just exactly and then they fill the
mold with plaster and they get an exact
copy of what you look like this is what
they did the Phineas Gage this is a year
after the accident and this is exactly
what he looked like exactly what he
looked like and if you notice you can
see there's a scar on his head now I'm
going to talk about some stuff appoint
two pictures and you're not going to be
able to really see but if you get the
book I want you to look really closely
at some of these things I'm telling you
one of the things I want you to look for
is the the dimple here in his forehead
and that's the scar but that's all you
could see okay there wasn't the like a
gaping hole in his head
because if there was a hole in his skin
he couldn't have lived because we all I
told you what a great friend your skull
is and I'll tell you what a great friend
your skin is your skin keeps all the
terrible things out of your body and
keeps your body inside very important
thing your skin okay hang onto your skin
all right so so that's what finished
look like people asked me to observe her
a photograph taken as far as anybody
knows nobody took his picture but the
other thing you have to remember is
pictures cameras were very new at the
time this happened in fact there aren't
very many pictures of anybody from this
time okay so he went to Harvard to the
medical school and the doctors he was
exhibited and they looked at him and
there was a man Tim and a lot of people
didn't believe what had happened to him
they thought maybe he'd been hit on the
head or something
because it didn't how could a man have a
hole in his head right
well this is a this is in 1848 around
1850 which was before the Civil War you
all know Abraham Lincoln Abraham Lincoln
was a young man when this happened okay
this was a long time ago and doctors at
that time did not know they didn't know
a lot of things doctors still don't know
a lot of things but back then they
didn't know how the brain worked they
didn't know how the brain worked me how
it functioned now does anybody ever seen
them on a mummy case an Egyptian mummy
mummies yeah well some people have seen
books about mummies okay
well the Egyptians used to take their
dead people wrap them up in bandages
to preserve the bodies right and they
would put the important things from the
end inside of the body in separate jars
they put the heart and the lungs and the
intestines and jars so that the person
going into the afterworld would have the
important stuff and they'd throw away
what they thought was unimportant one of
the things they threw away was your
brain because they didn't think it was
important because the interesting thing
is if you look at a heart in a person or
an animal you can see the heart when
it's beating you can guess that it's a
pump because you see it going like this
all the time if you look closely you can
sometimes you can see a little
circulation going out of the heart well
though that took a long time to figure
it out too for people but if you look at
a brain you can't see a thing you can't
see any thoughts in a brain if you
opened your head and look inside you
wouldn't see anything moving around yeah
they might do that - that might be
unimportant yeah Wow
uh-huh okay well but to see people had
different ideas about the brain and the
Greeks the ancient Greeks thought that
the brain was to cool your blood that's
what they thought the brain was for and
people talk about no when you fall in
love where do you love people from your
heart right right but you really don't
love people from your heart you love
people from your brain but we still say
that my heart is broken when you're when
you're unhappy about love and when you
send someone a card for Valentine's Day
it doesn't have a picture of a beating
brain that's a picture of a beating
heart but it took a while to figure this
out and so Phineas Gage came along at
the time when doctors in America and in
Europe were arguing about how the brain
was put together how the brain worked
and there were two groups two opinions
one group said the brain was like a big
room filled with sort of a cloud and
that thoughts moved back and forth in
the cloud everywhere in your brain and
it didn't matter what part of your brain
you were thinking in he was in another
part of your brain all the time the
other group decided that your brain was
broken down into little places where
special things happen right and then so
they both had theories and how did they
come to these theories they made them up
they had no information at all about how
the brain is actually organized so they
just simply made up their theories now
the group of people who believe that the
brain had lots of little places in it
they were called phrenologist and it's
one of those big words but basically
they drew up these pictures it showed
where all the places in your brain are
that do your thinking for you and they
believe for example that your language
took place under your left eye and that
friendship was determined on the back of
your head and all these kind of places
and they have all of them listed on
there for logical maps we just finished
this notate your question okay
okay and this is their their system now
how did they know how did they figure
they would know if you had a lot of
powers in this thing
and what they did was they felt four
bumps the phrenologist believed if you
had a bump over the place where you were
intelligent and meant that you had
strong intelligence we've had a little
dip in your head over the spot where you
say had continuity it meant that you
couldn't keep things together okay how
did they do this theory they made it up
they had no ideas but they made it up
and in the 19th century a lot of people
went around feeling the bumps on their
heads to figure out how they thought
okay so Phineas came along and both
sides decided that he proved their
theory because Phineas could walk he
could talk he could dress himself he
could count he could handle money he
could drive a horse he worked so
obviously the brain must be one big
place because he had his bar go through
the front of his brain and he was okay
the other group said ah
Phineas proves our theory which is that
the brain has lots of little places and
where things happen because he had
certain problems because his character
changed the way the kind of person he
was changed before and after the
accident that's a little bit tricky here
because not everybody knew that only
certain doctors did and I'll explain
that because the doctor who treated him
knew that he was different after he got
better but he didn't want to tell
everyone that he was different because
after the accident before the accident
Phineas was well-liked people listened
to him people who work for him like
working for him after he came back the
people who work for couldn't stand him
they said he was rude they said he said
nasty things to them they said he would
change his mind in a minute they didn't
want to work with him so Phineas didn't
work on the railroad after that so after
this accident
Phineas traveled around the world though
he traveled around and around New
England for a while and then he went
home
where I lived in New Hampshire place
called Lebanon and he worked in a stable
with horses and he was apparently very
good with horses okay and he worked
there for a year and then I met he met a
man who was starting a stagecoach line
in South America and Chile now have you
ever seen a Western moving the
stagecoach with the big wheels okay
that's called a Concorde stagecoach and
they were actually made in New Hampshire
and they were you'd and they had they
were controlled by six horses and they
carried nine passengers and the driver
and they carried luggage and they
carried guns and they carried treasure
and there were no there was no motor and
the way you controlled it as the driver
was with your hands and the reins
shouting at the horses so it was a very
skillful job he drove a stagecoach for
seven years after his accident in Chile
just working the Rings it's amazing so
he couldn't get along with people but he
could make horses do what he wanted and
so and he took care of himself and then
when he after seven years he began to
feel didn't feel right he felt something
was wrong so he took a ship from Chile
which is in South America up the Pacific
coast to California where his sister was
living his sister had married a man who
was a merchant in San Francisco so mrs.
gabe's that was Phineas gages mother
went to San Francisco to live with her
and Phineas came and joined them and
then when he got there he felt kind of
sick he felt not right but then he felt
better and then he went out he started
to work again he worked for farmers
plowing again with horses and but now he
began to have what's called epileptic
seizures I don't know if you've ever had
an experience in your life or in your
family with somebody with epilepsy it's
not a disease it's a symptom now what's
the difference between a disease and a
symptom okay when you get a cold or a
flu and you get really feverish you get
you feel very hot you've ever been sick
you felt really hot
your mom took your temperature said you
have a temperature that means you have a
fever that means your body temperature
has gone up
okay now the fever is a symptom that
there's something happening to you that
you have a virus like an influenza virus
and your body is fighting it off so
that's a symptom
so epilepsy is a symptom of something
going on in your brain and what it is is
an electrical storm
your brain is electrical and what's
happening is that the that the
electrical waves are getting out of sync
and they're sort of banging into each
other and going back and forth and what
it can do is it can cause your muscles
to suck to seize and then sort of go
like that if I have a cramp like in a
car during the movie theater and when
you stood up muscle felt all funny or
your if your hand falls asleep or
something
well epileps a seizure is sort of like
that except it makes your muscles go out
back can make your muscles go like this
all the time can make them move all the
time
so what happened to two Phineas was he
began to have seizures all the time and
they couldn't control them now it's Dave
if you have epilepsy doctors have a lot
of very good medications that can
control it and stop it from happening
but in his time they couldn't and that's
what killed him
eleven years after his accident okay now
I've been setting you up for this big
explanation we're going to look at this
picture enough not get upset okay
when Phineas died he was living in San
Francisco he died with his mother and
his sister sitting right next to him so
his family was there okay and after he
was dead
though this was in 1860 and the Civil
War or the Civil War they broke out
almost meeting thereafter now California
was a long way from Boston in those days
it wasn't even a railroad across the
country in those days to get a letter to
California had to send it on a by Pony
Express or by ship all the way around
the South America but dr. Harlow who was
the doctor way back in Vermont who
treated
finneus and when he was sick had lost
track but a friend told him or a friend
told him that mrs. gage was living in
San Francisco so he wrote to her and she
wrote back the Phineas had died in 1860
he didn't hear about this until 1866 so
six years after Phineas died when the
doctor found out he wrote to her and she
wrote back and she told him what had
happened to him how he'd gone to Chile
and driven a stagecoach and how he'd
come to San Francisco and how he died
and then he wrote and asked a very
special favor okay he asked that that
they open his grave and remove his skull
and send it back to Boston to the
medical school now he wanted it to show
to other doctors because if you remember
remember when he looked like this and he
went to Boston a lot of people did not
believe that he'd actually had something
go through his head because it's pretty
hard to believe right so he wrote to
Phineas mom and said I know this is a
lot to ask but I would like to show the
skull of your son at the Medical School
so people who can see what really
happened and she agreed now why would
you do that
that's right that's why the doctor
wander why do you think his mom would do
that I mean it's kind of it's it's kind
of stupid you know scary to dig somebody
up
it was
that's really true think of it this way
no this is his mom right Denise is dead
and his mom says that she will send his
skull back to Boston to the Medical
School to look at this is my theory I
think that the family really liked the
doctor and really felt that they'd saved
his life and that the doctor had stayed
Phineas's life and they felt very
grateful that that they really trusted
the doctor and taking care of their son
and now that he was dead they felt that
something important could come out of
his death that science could learn
something about it
so I go to this big thing because some
people say how could they do that
how could they dig up their son and send
his call back and I think they did it
because they really respected the doctor
and they wanted people to learn from
what had happened to their son okay they
sent the skull back all right okay he'd
been in the ground for six years okay
and when you're in a grave what happens
is your body melts away
your flesh goes away then the bacteria
eat the flesh and what's left is your
skeleton okay so that's what was left
when they opened his grave and they
removed it and there was something else
in the coffin the iron rod he carried it
all his life and he'd been buried with
it so they sent it back to Boston and
dr. Harlow cleaned it up and then he
made he took a saw and he cut it all the
way around the outside so he could lift
the top off he did that so you could see
what had happened and this is the skull
of Phineas Gage that's at the Harvard
Medical School right now and if you look
you can see this hole in the top of his
head is where the rod came out now there
was a big patch of bone when the rod hit
it remember grep was like being shot he
went up and the rod went out of his head
and then the doctor came and he pushed
it back and he bandaged it up and if you
look closely when you get a chance at
this picture you can see on this side
that it started to heal you can
tell that because the bone has grown
back now anybody here broken arm or a
leg or a foot
you've broken many I know you but
anybody else okay you break your arm
that your wrist okay when you're an old
man you're going to go to the doctor and
they're going to x-ray you for something
else and they're going to say oh you
broke your your wrist when you were a
baby right or a kid you can say how do
you know that and they say because you
can look on the x-ray and see where it
healed because your bones when they
break if the heal they'll heal up and
they'll close over and no fuse so when
dr. Harlow showed this skull in Boston
in 1868 he proved a that this that the
rod had gone through Phineas's head that
Phineas had survived because the bone
healed okay but the other thing is
remember in the back here you can't see
a hole because the skin had grown over
it but with the skull you can see that
the skin was just hiding a real hole in
his skull so and then when you took the
top off his head you can see the hole
under the but at the bottom of the brain
case you can see actually the path that
the brain that the rod went through his
brain now by the time Phineas came back
to Boston in 1868 doctors had decided
that the brain worked a third way not
like the bumps and not like the big room
but they were beginning to decide that
specific places on your brain did
specific things and that in fact is what
it does and since that time since
Phineas the case of Phineas Gage doctors
who started the brain they're called
neurologists have learned that more and
more of the behavior of the brain can be
traced to very specific places on your
brain here okay guys now put your finger
in your ear your left ear put your
finger on the top of your ear come
forward about two inches
okay now on your brain you're out you're
on the left-hand temporal lobe of your
brain here and there's a spot here
called the Wernicke's area where you
speak from okay I'll take your hand take
your hand down
now Phineas had a rod through the head
not too many people have that happen to
them and survived okay a lot of people
have a thing called strokes you may have
heard the word at some time or other and
it means there's a little vein in your
brain that breaks and blood comes out
into your brain and it what it does is
it damages the brain right there if it
damages the Vernick is area this place
you touched here with your finger you're
going to have a lot of trouble speaking
and sometimes if you've seen someone
who's had a stroke they have trouble
speaking and they go to physical therapy
and you can be taught to speak to learn
to work around but that's what we now
know is that for example there's speech
areas there's areas across the top of
your head to control your arms and your
legs in terms of space you know where
you are you know what you're sitting
upright or leaning forward we know that
for example you see your eyes your
visual centers are at the back of your
skull back here and your eyes cross in
the middle the nerves from your eyes
cross in the middle of your head and in
fact so your your right eye is is
activating a part of your brain at the
left side of your head and your left eye
is activating the part of your brain on
the right side here so nowadays they
have a thing called an MRI or a cat scan
machines and what they are you've seen
them on television they put the person
on a little bed and they roll them into
like a big doughnut if you ever seen
that on television you had four MRIs
well then someone knows what's in your
brain what they do is they can actually
see thinking remember we said before if
you opened your head you can see your
brain you wouldn't you wouldn't know
anything was going on
right but with an MRI it can see
chemical changes and electrical patterns
in your brain so
they can put someone in an MRI or a cat
or one of these other machines and ask
them for example to do arithmetic
problems and they can see what part of
your brain lights up well they can ask
them to remember things or they can
stimulate parts of their body or they
can do a lot of these kind of questions
and now we're getting a picture that
shows that your brain is very localized
what it does okay so come back to
Phineas Gage this case happened a long
time ago right before the Civil War when
Abraham Lincoln was a young man but in
1994 two doctors in Iowa were really
curious about where the rod had gone
because remember this little spot here
is speech right if the rod had gone
through here genius wouldn't have been
able to speak it had gone through here
he wouldn't have been able to understand
what's what's spoken another area I'm
sorry
this area is called Broca's area I've
made a mistake this is Broca and this is
Verna Keys areas further forward here on
the temporal lobe made amidst a lot of
words in this stuff huh so anyway they
took Phineas's skull they had someone
measure it again this thing and then
they put her down a computer that could
plot where the holes were in the skull
and then they could back it up and then
they could put in a brain if you look at
this picture you can see there's a brain
and the red line represents the rod you
see that so the rod is people ask oh
here you go
see it's like a cylinder all right I'll
bring it over here you guys are gonna
have to get and really study these
pictures close up you can really see
what's going to so you can really see
where it came out he came out right at
the front at the top of his head right
through here and this area it turns out
affects your personality
it affects who you are it affects your
ability to make decisions good decisions
and we see this now in patients who have
had with the Co brain tumors and
sometimes in very serious cases doctors
will go operate and they'll remove a
tumor from that part of
brain and doctors are very reluctant to
do that because they know that if you
touch this part of the brain people
change people who are sort of friendly
and easygoing can become sort of grumpy
or they could become really kind of not
nice people and then or they can just
become sort of you know fuzzy they don't
really sort of become very distant but
you're but who you are
your brain is controlled lot up here
okay what does this mean it means got to
take really good care of your head
alright take care of your skull wear a
helmet when you ride a bike or if you're
going to play football or you're going
to jump out of an airplane with a
parachute or if you're going to join the
infantry or if you're going to go cave
exploring wear a helmet now it wouldn't
have helped
finneus at all to have a helmet I have
to tell you that because if you remember
the rod came in from below fell from
above but you should take care of your
skull and the other thing is that you
probably should remember about Phineas
gages that he was a person just like you
and me to take some questions here my
family okay yeah see okay I don't know
and one I was just swinging it around a
pillar and I got and
and I got a deep cut I think it I can't
quite remember but if I remember right
hey I got cut right yeah it looks like a
yield so you see it healed over since
you're your friend your skin covered it
over which is a good deal though your
band-aid is you huh looks let's get some
other questions you okay good
but your healing that's the important
thing let's see let's work with over
here this we were waiting my cousin he
was writing um a half pipe on a
skateboard
yeah and he got a scab I speak my
goodness his cousin I got up is in a
skateboard accident but he's okay now
he's still skateboarding whoo his
parents ought to talk to back here
there's a question next to you what's
your question
yeah you stick though those think you
get shot that's a bad terrible thing
terrible thing here
yep right there
they had a number um you know I'm
sitting at the attorney I think they
thought there were 47 different
compartments in your head but they sort
of they made that up so now the doctors
know of hundreds of places in your head
to do things but it what they made up
was just made up yeah ah good question
why didn't Phineas died of blood loss
okay it's a really interesting question
your brain actually doesn't have a lot
of blood supply in it it actually has a
very it doesn't have big veins now if
Phineas had been shot in the heart he
would have died instantly because that's
where all your blood passes through your
heart right but your brain is kept
separate from the rest of your body by
it by its structure you have your skull
right and then it's wrapped in various
layers inside to keep your brain
separate and there's a thing called the
blood-brain barrier that keeps your
brain separate from the rest of your
bloodstream and keep certain protects
your brain from bacteria and stuff I
think anyway you're questioning
so when Allender is cheek there are no
big blood vessels in your under your
cheek and you came out the top of his
head it came out through the frontal
lobes and the other thing it missed the
the important blood vessels by not much
remember I showed you this picture of
the skull with the red line through it
and when they did this they came up with
they came up I think with nine possible
ways that this rod could have gone
through his head you know just a little
bit this way a little bit that way and
they ruled out five of them immediately
because they would have struck blood
vessels and he would have died instantly
so in a sense but this rod passed
precisely through the place in his head
where he would not have bled to death so
that explains yeah
we'll say out if you like this is
everything BRE knees know your brains
bigger than that well your brain so your
brains a little bit bigger than that mmm
well your uh but look here's your head
right this your brain runs from here
back to here it comes down to about here
so they it's usually described as a very
big walnut but I don't think that's
going to help you a lot it's it's about
that big in an adult a kid would have a
smaller brain anybody want to help me
out here any doctors in your house like
to tell me what the weight of a brain is
I think it's
two or three pounds wet or dry I think I
think I've seen three depends on you who
you are but not not too big not too
small okay what why did he lose sweating
why was he blind in the left eye he did
by the way people ask so vast me in the
past did he lose his sight he did lose
the sight in his left eye he didn't lose
the eye the eye was still there but
immediately after he the accident he
could see according to witnesses and
apparently the rod passed and did not
sever didn't cut the nerve the optic
nerve to his left eye but it damaged it
and I what happened was probably over
time was the damage got worse and we
really didn't discuss this about what
happens when your brain gets hit okay
what happens if you bang your hand like
if you hit yourself with a hammer or a
board hits you what is your finger gets
smashed what happens how's it feel
smaller
does you have ever looked at it bruise
what is it is it bigger or littler
bigger it swells when you hurt something
it can swell so when your brain gets
hurt it swells and that's called a
concussion and that's why doctors
wouldn't if you're falling off your
bicycle or herger oh wow yeah it hurt
well but doctors are very worried about
concussion because what happens is is if
you if you rattle your brain your skull
is hard and your brain is soft so if you
bounce the soft part of your brain
against your skull it can actually swell
and why that is dangerous is your skull
doesn't get any bigger once you're grown
so if your brain is swelling it's
pressing against the skull and that can
damage you can cut off circulation to
your
to your brain damage it okay so what
happened when the optic nerve when his
nerve was hit with the rod was he
probably started to swell once it
swelled it probably you know got hurt
and then gradually he lost the sight was
left like he could seem his right eye
though and he and you wouldn't have
known to look at him that he couldn't
see in his left eye unless you went up
to his eye but like that you didn't
react to you okay question um I'll tell
you a to the day he was he was 26 years
old and he lived another 11 years so he
was 37 when he died okay so he was a
young man I know 26 sounds pretty old to
you but but for four people he was quite
young yeah so some more questions
personality changing there any stories
of him getting in trouble for anything
specific to the many crimes or anything
well that's an interesting question um
this is a famous story right people have
told this story many many times and
there were a lot of stories about him
getting in trouble being arrested and by
the police in Boston and stuff but a man
a professor of psychology in Australia
named Malcolm Macmillan spent a lot of
time doing research on this could find
no proof no evidence that this had ever
happened that this was just stories that
people had made up as far as we know the
only trouble he got into was trouble
with people he couldn't get along with
people
he couldn't the people he worked for
with the railroad let him go he quarrel
with people people said that he would
use vulgar language when he shouldn't in
that vulgar language oh you know there's
certain cuss words that you're not
supposed to use around the table or when
you have your grandmother visiting you
and he would use those kind of words and
places he shouldn't and that is
restaurants or or with ladies presence
or things like
that you know being human is not just a
matter of of you know dressing right or
driving a nice car it's also a matter of
knowing how to get along with people and
to let people know that you're friendly
or not friendly or that you're polite or
not polite and what the biggest trouble
that Phineas got into was that he didn't
really seem to know how to be human
anymore they didn't really know how to
get along with strangers or how to
convince people to help him and stuff
like that and that's this that's
interesting that you could be injured by
something physical and what would change
would be your ability to get along with
people okay we'll take Tim and then
we'll end up with you okay oh my god I
was punching the garbage bag and I got a
deep cut right here just a little tiny
mark tiny mark okay so you can imagine
if you've got punched in the head and
you had a big mark like this okay so you
see your skin is very important take
care of your skin okay you have a
question now ah well something to tell
you um I um you know how you said it
changed his ability to like be nice well
that's kind of how I am I I can't I
don't really know how to make friends
cuz I can't I don't I do well just you
know what you're still pretty young you
know and you learn how to make friends
as you get older
yes you hang around with people you
figure it out you look like you have
your whole skull there like my friend
Angelique you ah I like go up and like I
don't ask her and family I wake up
ah well you gonna ask people for you
touch her now that's the big rule that's
what I'm talking about yeah well those
are the class actually what we're
talking about with Phineas those are the
rules like when you touch people when
you don't touch people those are the
rules that he had trouble with after his
accident yeah but I said you're young
you learned you're learning a lot of you
can't drive a car you can you can't fly
a plane don't speak Italian hey about
time you seemed so cool oh okay you're
learning stuff one more question
um I saw this movie called Ottoman X in
this guy on um a jeribai we're on this
tram tried to do a backflip um and fell
off his bike and for like a hundred feet
in the air fell on his back ooh doesn't
sound good so you see that kind of stuff
looks good on film but there's two
things you learn about from Phineas Gage
one is that the your body is pretty
tough that that someone could take this
kind of a damage and and keep living and
the other thing is your body is pretty
pretty fragile you have to take care of
it and I don't suggest that you jump out
of bicycles that are 100 feet in the air
start beating it Phineas was
strange or possessed or something
because it didn't hurt here no I didn't
think so I think people thought that Oh
lumber people didn't think he was
actually injured in the brain they just
thought he'd had a bad accident and I
don't think you know his friends really
knew that much about it what had
happened to him they just thought he'd
been really sick and sometimes people
really sick are different when they get
better you know I think if that was the
the only thing that anybody said but the
thing about Phineas Gage and thing in
this book is I there's so much I would
love to know about him I'd love to talk
to him for half an hour just to see what
he was like afterwards and I'd like to
talk to some of the people who knew him
to ask them one of the questions is he
went to South America lived there for
seven years and I know a number of
doctors would really like to know if he
was able to learn another language while
he was down there or whether his ability
to learn was affected so these are a lot
of questions that nobody knows the
answer to and we probably never will but
that's what interests me about this
story's in it after the session we're
going to have this he's going to find
some books and
okay John Fleischman is a science writer
for the American Society for cell
biology Phineas Gage a gruesome but true
story about brain science as published
by Houghton Mifflin online at Houghton
Mifflin books